well now should you boycott Pierce
Morgan that's me of course a number of
people seem to think so online the
hashtag has been trending all week
pushed by several high profile Muslims
and pro Palestinian accounts as despite
the show in my opinion doing more to
give a platform to Pro Palestinian
voices since this War Began than any
other probably in the
world end the blockade the end the
aparte the end the occupation the the
the notion that Israel is defending
itself is as absurd as the notion that
the rapist is defending itself from the
victim that's a big charge to make about
he he has just lied before getting any
evidence dealing with Israel is so
difficult it's like being in a
relationship with a narcissistic
psychopath one man's terrorist is
another man's Freedom Fighter have you
never heard that Palestinians
are just numbers they are not numbers
they are
human well despite this the campaign
against he's been led by the a Institute
and backed by several prominent voices
in the community here's what lawyer
Muhammad akuni the former lawyer of Isis
bride shamima beum had to say the fellow
is just acting like a petulant child he
might as well frankly interview himself
with a mirror on his show at this point
absolutely no manners behaves
appallingly it's actually embarrassment
so until unless he can demonstrate that
he knows now how to interview people
with a bit of good manners and Grace
then uh I just don't want to hear it
anymore I suggest everyone boycott him
well tonight I thought I'd face this
boycott head on in sens of style with as
much good grace and manners as I can
must joining me to discuss this is a
deputy editor of Muslim News website
Five Pillars Dilly husin which has
written and spoken a lot about this week
about why Muslims should be boycotting
me so Mr Hussein thank you for joining
me why should I be boycotted my my
position is as I've just shown with that
mashup genuinely genuinely do not think
there's a television news show in the
world that has given a more consistent
or bigger platform to Pro Palestinian
voices and honestly the only interviews
that have got fractures have come when
I've asked the question do you view
Hamas as terrorist you condemn what they
did on October the 7th and if people
prevaricate then I have got angry
because I just think that's
non-negotiable to their credit many pro
Palestinian voices haven't tried to do
that they've accepted it was an
appalling terrorist attack and then we
move on to often very civilized debate
but you know if you can't assess what
happened then for what it clearly was I
I have a problem with that now I just
think overall I don't get the boycott
why would you want to stop people
watching a show that has so many voices
giving your side of this story is our
segment going to be as courteous as the
one you just did with Mark reg you think
that was courteous I think it was
courteous and respectful do you think we
can have that engagement do you think I
asked him good questions you g you gave
him enough time to answer that inter you
know what I think about Mar R he's
always very respectful to me he answers
the questions you may not agree with the
ANW all your questions but when people
come on Jeremy Corbin the doctor earlier
this week when people come on and simply
won't give a yes or no answer to a yes
or no question that also can be
aggravating you know I don't look
sometimes I get a bit intemperate
sometimes I do get a bit emotional about
stuff it's an emotional story right you
want to use this opportunity to
apologize to one billion Muslim women no
why is that because it was completely
misconstrued because he was in response
to the whole Li um filth it right so the
context my question was that if you want
to treat women in the way that this
member of his organization why was that
your instinctive response because I felt
that that quote was so disgusting that
one of his own group had talked about
needing to get rid of a secular law
bring in Sharia law so he could get rid
of LGBT filth and feminist filth and
then the first reaction of a doctor was
to say I agree and I was like really
that's how you want to treat women you
want to treat women as feminist filth
now it got clipped up purely as me
saying what you want them to be a
pressed that wasn't what I said I don't
think actually anyone who watched the
whole thing you seen your monologue
people have seen your monologue yeah
yeah they've seen your clarification and
they're still and it's still trending
yes because the original clip was so
misleading it made out that I think all
women who are Muslims are oppressed or
all those who want to become Muslims
would be heading towards oppression I
don't feel that so you don't want to so
you don't want to apologize to those
Muslim women who were offended no I want
to apologize to anybody who watched the
clip that was put out and was and listen
and in my view was Del Al misled delber
misled because I don't believe that what
about your statement from 2019 you and I
on the LGBT issue you described Muslim
parents protesting peacefully within the
law of the land as they're behaving as
if they're in Islam Abad do you stand by
that comment what was remind me of that
Muslim parents in Birmingham protesting
against lgbtq education to be taught to
four or fivey olds you said twice with
saman fared and I had to check you the
second time you said why are they
behaving like it's Islamabad okay well I
don't remember us doing that but I'll go
and check it I'll give you a response
when I've checked it if if you did say
that do you think that's an appropriate
comment it depends I mean it depends I'm
trying to remember I was on Good Morning
Britain right so this is four years ago
I'd have to go back and look at it I
would have probably taken a view that if
people were protesting in a very
aggressive manner about LGBT education I
would probably think at the time that
that was inappropriate why slad I don't
know I have to go back and look at the
quote right and have instinctive
response okay but you haven't mentioned
this before so you've mentioned it to me
now I'll go back and watch it I will
I'll go back and watch it I'll give you
a response but let's get to Sharia law
do you hate Sharia law I don't hate
Sharia law you said you said you know
about Sharia law so what credentials I
know I know that Sharia law operates in
a number of countries around the world
and I know that in someone like
Afghanistan the women who under Sharia
law imposed by the Taliban are deeply
oppressed would you agree with that what
qualifications talk about would you
agree with that what qualification would
you agree have what qualifications do
you have let's trying to reach points of
agreement do you agree that the way the
Taliban treats women is oppression I
want to I'm going to answer your
question can you answer it I I will
answer your question we answer it I want
to know why don't answer supplementary
first answer my question you said you
know about Sharia law I just asked you a
specific question just want to know what
your credentials are speak about this
I'm just asking you about the situation
in Afghanistan there with a Taliban
interpretation and implementation of
sharia law in my opinion and the opinion
of most people outside of Afghan who's
most people well I'm about to ask you
whether you agree with it do you think
the way women are treated in Afghanistan
by the Taliban there are aspects
isession or not there are aspects of
misapplication of no education there's
an P we we're going down that road again
aren't we well you tell me I've just
said to you there are misapplication of
sharia law not just in Afghanistan
across the bre is the Taliban
misapplying it I'm asking you what is
your expertise to comment on this Sor
it's my show I do the question but you
invited me I'm just asking you a
question you haven't answered it is the
Talan implenting sh Laur accurately or
not not entirely and comprehensively
okay so we can agree that there there is
is oppression of women there is most
certainly aspects to reform and review
in the education system of Afghanistan
would you would you say the way women
are treated in Afghanistan right now by
Taliban is oppressive I don't appreciate
this line of questioning peace of course
you don't because you know why you know
why someone will clip up you saying
Taliban are oppressing women and before
you know it Dilly you will be trending
worldwide everyone will go wow Dilly
Hussein says Muslim women are oppressed
you see how easy it is to this type of
questioning what makes people think you
are islamophobic this is why you want to
boycott me because you don't want me
asking difficult questions it's got
nothing to do with a J don't want me
asking difficult questions so the reason
why people are calling for your boycott
is because you offended one billion
Muslim women no I didn't yes you did no
yes why why is it trending okay as I've
just said to you I could stand by I can
now clip up you criticizing the Talib
wait criticizing the way Taliban treat
women under Sharia law I could clip just
that bit of you stammering and looking
awkward and conceding it's not right
right and then before you know it it
becomes Dilly Hussein whacks the Taliban
this is wrong women are being oppressed
blah blah blah and you'll sit there
going hang on but that's how it works
it's misleading it's deliberate it's
antagonistic I don't have form you have
form no I don't you have form no I don't
do you want to give me the example you
want give the example I'll give you let
me give you a better example let's go
back to 2003 when this country my
country launched an illegal invasion of
Iraq okay right who stood up then right
for Iraqis who stood up for innocent
people in Iraq and launched the biggest
media campaign against the British
government in modern times me right do
you know that do you remember that do
you give me any credit for that or do
you look at me as the Muslim Basher
because I'm not and you know I'm not so
we going back to 2003 why don't we talk
about 2019 why don't we talk about you
went back first no the fact that you
have no qualifications to talk about
Jihad you don't even have a primary
principles basis to talk about no
qualifications I've been a journalist
for 35 years I've had to cover I've had
to cover this for 35 years and you never
posed these such questions to any of
your Israeli guests about why just heard
me 10 minutes questions Netanyahu and
Senior diplomats who have used Biblical
verses biblical vers of Alik to carry
out genocide have you questioned anyone
about that did you watch my show last
night did you question did you watch my
show last night no I didn't okay okay
you wouldn't have seen Norman finlin
then for half an hour talking exactly
about that I'm talking about yourself
questioning your guests you've just
literally heard me grilling netanyahu's
spokesman you call that a grilling I
think so yes yeah you call that a
grilling yes and by the way if you
answer the questions in the same
respectful way he does and answer the
questions it would be more respectful no
because you won't answer the questions
what question do you want answered I
just asked you do you condemn the way
the Taliban treat women I just said to
you that there are applications and
misapplications of sharia law not just
in Afghanistan across the breath of the
Muslim World okay let's go over the
stuff that was contentious with the
doctor right I asked him was what
happened October the 7th a terror attack
was was it I believe it to be a military
offensive by various factions of
Palestinian groups not just Hamas and
many of them are not even banned under
UK law was it a terrorist attack pardon
was it a terrorist attack have you come
to an agreement about what it means to
be a ter I've got the full rundown of
what terrorism is as I had at the time
you didn't you no no I had it I wanted
to know what the doctor's interpretation
of I'm not the doctor what's your
interpretation of terrorism terrorism
yeah is an act of violence targeting
children and civilians to advance the
political correct is that what Hamas did
on October
7th is that what you think is that what
you think I'm asking you I don't believe
it was an act of terrorism no you don't
no okay even though they literally did
what you just articulated as a
definition of terrorism you have proof
that they targeted women and children's
civilians specifically what's the proof
I'll tell you the proof what's the proof
the GoPro videos oh you don't think it
happened oh the GoPro videos so w like
the doctor you deny I've seen the videos
I'm a journalist I've authenticated the
videos I've seen the videos but show me
the proof that women and children were
specifically targeted as opposed to they
were literally burned alive homes okay
where's the proof people were beheaded
proof babies were killed name me one
child one child was beheaded name me one
child that was beheaded and I will mourn
and condemn with you I just said people
were beheaded I didn't say a child not
primary source objected no no so what
just to be clear to be clear like the
doctor you do not believe that anyone
was beheaded that children were killed I
me clarify where I'm wrong here were
were these things
happening Israeli civilians were killed
how many I don't know Mark doesn't even
know we need to First establish they do
know many we know at least 1200 people
including around 400 uh soldiers so
we're assuming 800 civilians were killed
and we know at least many of were killed
at least another 200 odd civilians were
taken hostage right how many them were
killed by Israel how many you think a
lot higher than a lot yes is there's no
evidence of that of course is no it's
not look at the Nova just look at the
Nova Music Festival I look at the burnt
out cars doesn't even see this is the
problem isn't it the real reason you
want me boycotted is I'm telling the
truth and what you're doing is trying to
convince viewers and maybe your Muslim
fan base I don't know um you're trying
to convince them that what we saw
Through The Eyes of hamas's own
technology where they gloated and
boasted about what they' done didn't
happen and you want me to think and you
want me to think that even though you
articulate hang on you articulated a
description of terrorism and then said
that didn't apply to October 7th even
though that's exactly what happened you
see I would say that's delusional I
would say it's deliberately misleading
as was the attempt to try and make me
apologize to Muslim women for apparently
call which I didn't do you stand by that
comment you you couldn't care less about
the offense caus to 1 billion Muslim
women or 1.8 billi Muslim about talking
about Jad and the sacred law of Muslims
there was a deliberate deliberate
attempt to misquote me out of context to
try and make out that the way you
interpreted it anyone who watched the
whole exchange knew what I was doing but
when you have a member of that group
talking about FY commit terrorism sorry
I don't okay do you believe State actors
can commit terrorism it's possible it's
possible you don't believe Israel has I
do not with those figures that are
screaming at you at your face if you
again if you had watched the show last
night you would have seen my monologue
was a strident criticism I don't watch
your monolog of religious you know what
maybe you should watch a bit more if you
want to boycott the show if you want
people to stop watching me it might be
useful if you ever watch it I do watch
it here and there do you though Dilly or
do you watch the odd little clip on
social media been context and then you
say boycott this guy the issue isn't
about boycotting PS Morgan per se it's
about unless you rectify the way you
deal with your Muslim guests then
boycott is on the options that's what it
is now if you're saying did Hamas commit
an act of terrorism I've made it
abundantly clear it was a military
offensive by various factions not just
Hamas now it wasn't a military offense
it was was it it was a terrorist attack
against predominantly civilians who were
brutalized they were
tortured headed decapitated Palestinian
children isn't terrorism is it 7,000
children dead without heads actual
without heads again if you head Without
Limbs again if you had watched my show
last night you would have heard exactly
what my view of this was but here's the
thing you did the president of the
United States thinks have been
indiscriminately bombing so basically
you're just going to parot wherever
Biden says is that what it is no I'm
going to say do you not have a conscious
of the president of the United States
has Intelligence of indiscriminate
bombing that is a war crime we've heard
the denial took 70 days we've heard the
denial but if it turns out United States
has Intelligence of indiscriminate
bombing that is a war crime and I will
call it for what it is right is what is
what's going is what hang on is what's
going on in Gaza horrible yes is it
disproportionate I believe it is are
they going to win against toas and wipe
them all out I don't think they are is
America going to lose patience for
it's not ethnic cleansing it's not
genocide no it's not because that
actually involves the eradication of an
entire people if they wanted to they
could drop a nuclear bomb on Gaza and
kill everybody there that would be
genocide I don't believe it qualifies a
genocide right and these terms are
important are the Palestinians being
treated are the Palestinians as he's
articulated last night at length and
very powerfully and we had a very
reasonable conversation by the way right
I commend you to watch it go back and
watch it and maybe you wouldn't be
calling for boycots right genuinely
you're very triggered about being
boycott aren yeah because I feel I I
feel it's really unfair I do because i'
a I don't think you've been watching the
show and that's quite clear watch some
of and that's quite clear I don't think
you watch me sit with Bassam MF for two
hours and really try and get under the
weeds of this conflict with somebody who
can talk me all through it right so why
didn't Muhammad hijab get that same
treatment low Kei get that same
treatment why get that same treatment
I've do you know how do you know how
religiously I have actually watched
certain episodes that on average you
interrupt your Muslim guest 21.3 3
seconds really what's your views on that
did you watch the basam YF interiew no
no no no I said I literally interviewed
him for more than any other gu excluding
basam YF excluding him how many other we
exclude there was another Palestinian
doctor that I interviewed at length and
never interrupted him once whenever
you've had segments where 15 20 with the
Muslim guest why do you interrupt every
27.3 you know who it is I interrupt it's
the extreme elements oh not these labels
yeah why am I extreme exp your VI my
extreme because you are your attempt to
deny what happened October the 7th is an
extremist response refusal to call it
terrorism is an extremist resp have
there we have it so I believe you are an
islamophobe and a genocide enabler for
not using the correct term to describe
Israel's indiscriminate genocide that's
fine you're perfectly entitled to call
me that we are you got to actually
produce evidence of that produce
evidence of that yeah 7,000 children not
remotely islamophobic never have been
never will be right ever right back to
when I led the campaign against the Iraq
War okay in the this country against my
own government okay right never have
been it's an unly slur you've tossed
around because you've seen some
misconstrued clips from an interview
with a guy who wanted to deny the Hamas
a terrorist for the committed the terror
attack and the reason you did that and
fueled it is because you yourself don't
think what happened October Echo the
sentiments I firmly Echo the sentiments
of the 91% of
13,550 people ped that believe you an
islamophobe let me ask you if if you
want to boycott me yeah and shut me up
and not give me any exposure that was
never the that was never the end goal by
the way it was always a case of the
community reviewing how we engage with
people you want to stop Muslims coming
on the show unless you fix up the way
you engage with them yeah okay so what
are you doing here huh what am I doing
here I nearly pulled out are I came this
close oh because barati your producer
been on my case but why are you here to
converse to disc you're a grown man no
I'm here to check with did my Booker
bully you into it what did you did my
Booker bully you into it not at all so
why you here I'm here to ask you
squarely are you an islamophobe no so
can you clarify those statements about
Muslim women being oppressed I've
already I've already I've already
clarified not apologize for it so that
means you stand by it I've clarified it
stand by what do you know about Shia law
I clarified it for you do you apologize
also clarified I've also clarified that
you believe the Taliban is oppressing
women in Afghanistan no I believe when
did I say that you see how easy is to
twist things see how easy is to twist
things anyone who rejects P's version
which is basically the Israeli version
of events they're an extremist they're
terrorized sympathize who are you going
to tag after this interview you got no
one to tag have you I think the the
story out of this will be that you have
attacked the Taliban for the treatment
of women who you is kind of ironic isn't
who are you going to tag H who are you
going to tag after this exchange who am
I going to tag oh I did I tell you why I
tagged that I tell you why because I
genuinely believe it is wrong that a a
doctor in the NHS in country can hang on
can publicly support a terrorist group
who is which is an illegal entity in
this country hang on Hamas is prescribed
terror group he said what they did was
resistance that is supporting them it is
it is not saying they're terror group
this country says they are what he did
was a crime by coming on this program
it's a crime you may not think so when
did you become the law enforcement
agency of the I'm sorry I'm not the law
enforcement you're a journal is a
criminal it is a criminal as you know
from those who've been supporting a mass
at the protest if you publicly support a
prescribed terror group in this country
it is a crime so choosing to resistance
of terrorism is his support is that it
is support yes okay so can I ask you
just one last thing sure one last thing
the act of Great Britain in liberating
Europe under Nazi occupation was
resistance yes it was was resist of
course it was resisting we were def
you're resisting a foreign Invader in
the continent but we were we were taking
down the Nazis okay you're taking out
well guess what according to the
Palestinians they're taking down the
Israeli occupied Colonial settlers do
you see where we can just carry on we
can just carry
on what do we here the thing do we do I
want to have that conversation can we
have it more respectfully in the future
yes we can Wicked but don't try and
launch a boycott to stop the one guy
who's putting up more Palestinian voices
anyone else in the world why do you
interrupt every 27.3 seconds with most
your Muslim gu if you'd watched last
night for the whole show you would have
seen I didn't it depends who the guest
is and how they're behaving have I you
today well only when you don't answer
questions which question of have I not
answered a lot you won't even realize it
go back and watch it and you didn't
answer a lot either go back and watch it
but here's the point we've reached a
point of a bit more of a civilized
dialogue right we can do that I would
like to have that with you you treat
your Muslim guest better I do with
dignity you're not watching enough of
the interviews no I've seen Abdul I've
seen I've seen low key I've seen zlo
I've seen all these episodes no you're
not watching you're not you're watching
isolated shows with people who come in
and by the way are very aggressive with
me which is fine if they're going to be
aggressive with me I'll be aggressive
back if people want to be calm and
respectful as Norman thinkl Ste was last
night I'll be calm and respectful back
if you chose to be like that tonight I'd
have been in the same way with you it's
been a bit of mission match bit of Miss
match come back again let's keep having
the dialogue it's important I would like
to think we can be constructive on do
you promise to treat your Muslim guests
better according to what they accuse you
of no here no because the idea that
somehow I'm an islamophobe Bears no
relation to what viewers who watch the
show every night would think you haven't
watched the show very often you've made
it what's views on the what's your views
on the millions tens of millions of
Muslims and non-muslims in global South
countries have taken to the streets to
voice support for the events of 7th of
October I think they're wrong tens of
millions yes hundreds of millions you
through the breath of the Muslim by the
way it's wrong to support any terror
attack okay when hundreds and hundreds
of civilians are brutally medely
barbarically murdered in that manner the
only human response is to say it is
wrong you support terrorism who supports
terrorism if you support what they did
on October 7th you support terrorism
that's an absolute gratuitous accusation
and not there terror group by the way
you're in England where there are terror
group prescribed by the UK government
but you have described according to your
own definition that if you choose to not
say it's terrorism but resistance that's
support where did you get that from if
it's called resistance not terrorism
you're supporting them resistance is
just a coinage of a term to describe a
political act of violence that's what it
is resistance do you support what they
did no no I'm asking you no no I do the
question do you support what they then I
believe in the right of every single
Palestinian to do what is enshrined and
protected Terror yes because you reject
international law when it applies to
Muslims and Palestinians to commit an
act of
terrorism I'm not doing this P not doing
what answering a question I believe in
the right of pales is that why you want
to boycott me no I'm s I'm talking to
you yeah but you Palestinians have you
dug yourself into a very strange place
you've ended up saying that basically
you believe in every Palestinian right
to commit terrorism I believe right of
every Palestinian to resist setler
colonialism according to international
law the first protocol of Geneva
conventions 1949 1982 resolution so you
do support what happened October 7 you
support what happened October the 7th I
support whatever happened that they were
allowed to do within international law
of all Palestinian factions involved and
you think what happened was within
international law pardon you think what
happened was lawful according to
international law yes you think what
happened October the 7th was lawful yeah
Dilly honestly I would love to try I
would love to try and end
disrespectfully interal that is the
biggest croc of crap I've ever heard in
my life your your you think 12200 people
being murdered is not a crime and I
believe that the fact that you cannot
even call a war crime and a genocide
when he takes 19,000 people is
absolutely cure as well okay then we
agree on Mutual manure there we are but
I appreciate you coming on thank you for
having and defying your own boycott
okay